i think it's time we rap
oh you know what i i want to say it i
should have said this sooner but but i i
say this often and i mean it every time
which is that
i can't thank you enough and i can't
express enough gratitude
just in general like how much it means
to me that in all of my little
like uh side projects all my little
stevo things like how you've always
taken the time to
to to read my books to watch my videos
to critique my comedy specials like no
matter what the project is
everything i've ever sent you and asked
you for feedback not only have you taken
the time to really really check out the
project but you've given like
very thoughtful constructive
feedback and and you didn't ever have to
do that and and you doing that like it
makes me feel so emotional like i i
could just cry because because your
support in in doing that for me
uh [ __ ] it it means the world to me well
i love you and i'm proud of you and i'm
happy to see you flourishing and you
know so um happy to do it i love you and
i love you buddy
i like i i love you so much man your
opinion matters so much to me you're uh
you're like you're a big brother figure
you're a hero
you're uh you're the captain man and um
you know
everything good in my life really came
from you my sobriety my career
well
like i helped in some areas but none of
this would happen if it hadn't been for
you right you took responsibility you
kicked the ass you stayed committed like
why am i i gave you nudges a couple of
times but you're the one who took
the bull by the horns i think that works
here
and that's what's so impressive like
there's a lot of people that have
you know have uh chemical
dependency issues or whatever they're
dealing with and they can never they can
never get it licked but like
credit to you you know you
not only have
taken care of that but i've never seen
you better in your whole life well thank
you man
you got me started in every one of those
good things in my career and my sobriety
it was you who got me started and uh i'm
i'm so grateful for that and and i
really think too that
that our relationship is is stronger
better closer
now than it ever has been before and
yeah that's accurate yeah we're
we're clear yeah right we're we're we're
absolutely clear
and uh you know i'm easier to be around
than i used to be still kind of tough
small doses is better
me too like i i have my issues in uh
uh where's
i would stay distracted with what i was
distracted with you would you were the
same way you were headed one way i was
always headed another and now it's like
we can sit and talk yeah i i love it so
much i love you thank you love you buddy
thank you for my life and my career
that's a little that's stretching it but
it's a good way to end he's a showman
he's a showman people oh yeah
goodnight everybody
yeah dude